welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain I'd like to introduce to you
dr. not important and dr. Ashley finds
here who will be co-presenting today's
talk entitled invasive human neuro
physiological recordings for basic
science is altruism enough doctor
protein is an associate professor of
Neurosurgery and radiation oncology and
affiliated faculty in bioengineering and
neuroscience at UCLA dr. fine singer is
an adjunct assistant professor in the
Department of Medicine and Department of
Philosophy at UCLA and has unique
expertise in issues at the intersection
of ethics medicine and biomedical
research for a complete biography of our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen my name is dr.
Veronica Shannon and I will be your
moderator for today's event we were
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab woods we
would like to extend our special thanks
to the brain initiative program
directors in particular dr. James mad
for their efforts in organizing today's
session before we mean I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting questions
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions in the drop-down box
for the following this presentation we
will be offering a unique opportunity to
directly discuss the ethical
considerations of using new neuro
technologies in a line panel Q&A which
will take place today at 11:20 a.m.
Pacific time and 2:20 p.m. Eastern Time
any questions that we don't have time to
address to our speakers will be answered
following the presentation by an email
the presentation is educational and this
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window follow
the process to obtain your credits now
without any further ado please join me
in welcoming dr. Nora gratin and dr.
Ashley Pines here
I I'm NATO karate I'm a neurosurgeon at
UCLA here with Ashley fine singer in our
Department of Philosophy at UCLA we're
gonna be speaking to you about invasive
human neurophysiological recordings for
basic science is altruism enough
our discussion is going to be focusing
on ethical issues that have been raised
by some of the studies that we've done
in humans here's an outline of our topic
I'm going to first start with a
description of the landscape of clinical
trials with respect to therapeutic
content which will frame the rest of our
discussion and gives some specific
examples from NIH and brain funded
research programs that have brought to
light the ethical issues particularly
related to altruism finally I'm going to
hand it over to Ashley to talk about
altruism as golden motive and some of
the issues that we have learned about
with respect to considering altruism and
then we'll tie it back to real-life
applications so as I think about the
spectrum of clinical trials that we can
do in humans we traditionally think
about therapeutic clinical trials where
someone would enroll in a study with
some kind of anticipation that they may
benefit if the item being investigated
is intended for therapy content that
would potentially help the individual
help the group of patients that they're
in for example a Parkinson's disease
patient would potentially add to the
knowledge for patients with parking
disease as well as help society in
general and but there are when we get to
basic science and translational studies
studies where there is no therapeutic
intense meaning that by participating
these studies individuals may not
benefit directly but we may learn
something about patients with
Parkinson's disease and of course any
kind of knowledge gained is a benefit to
society but we can go one step removed
even further where there are patients
who can participate in a clinical trial
and as it may be an invasive study as
we're going to talk about where there's
no intent of helping the individual
patient and no intent of even increasing
our knowledge for example a patient with
Parkinson's disease but just trying to
understand how the brain works I'm going
to give you some examples of these so
that we can better under
and the ethical issues that arise I'm
going to start with these human clinical
trials to understand disease so one
example from my laboratory and several
other labs is this idea of using
neurosurgical procedures to learn about
the very diseases that we're treating in
my practice I implant deep brain
stimulator leads in patients with
parkinson's disease the patients are
often awake during these surgeries and
that gives us a very unique opportunity
to understand the physiology of
Parkinson's and so in addition to the
leads that I may place deep within the
brain
I will temporarily place an electric
orthographic strip on top of the brain
that's something we wouldn't normally do
for therapeutic purposes is purely for
research purposes and we can use some
advanced image registration algorithms
to figure out where those electrodes are
and now we can study physiology from
multiple points in the brain to gain a
better understanding of how Parkinson's
disease actually affects the brain so
for example this is one of our reports
in which we record signals from deep
within the brain from the Globus
pallidus internus signified by GPI there
on the left side of the slide and you
can see a demonstration of what we call
phase amplitude coupling in the rest
phase and that goes away with movements
and if you look just to the right of
that there's a GPE rest which looks
different than the GPI and GPI moving so
we get these dynamic pictures of what is
going on in the physiology of the brain
more importantly on the right side of
the slide we see that those signals that
are depicted on the left side actually
have clinical correlates so we see that
this PA see the phase amplitude coupling
correlates with symptom severity both
with regards to a measure that we call
UPD RS but then also rigidity and brady
kinesia we could see how much those
signals change with movement so what
we've really identified here by studying
patient Parkins of these is a biomarker
of symptom severity and you can imagine
that although the people who participate
in these studies don't benefit from this
we've learned something about
Parkinson's disease and hopefully we can
use this to help other
Parkinson's disease in the future
perhaps designing a more advanced deep
brain stimulation system one other
example here we showed that we can gain
insights into how deep brain stimulation
works that it disrupts Network synchrony
and we showed here that with the DBS off
there's a high level of network
synchrony and that when we turn this the
deep brain stimulator on that high beta
synchrony coupling between the motor
cortex and the Globus pallidus actually
decreases so again the people who
participate in this study don't get any
therapeutic benefit from having
participated but we've learned something
and we can hopefully help other people
with Parkinson's disease in the future
from what we've learned but we can go
one step remove a lot of these patients
that I operate on we will conduct
studies not to understand Parkins
disease but to understand how the brain
itself works this is another study that
I work on multi-institutional where
we're trying to understand parallel
circuits between the cortex and deep
within the brain the basal ganglia and
how they work to regulate movements
under conditions where you need to
select an action where there's
conflicting actions or when you need to
stop an action none of this has to do
with parking disease but they're very
fundamental questions of human
neuroscience and doing these in patients
who are undergoing deep brain submission
provides a very unique opportunity
here's just some examples where we see
that for example in the middle column
under SGA and you see that there is a
signal in the theta range that's
increased during periods of conflict we
also see that there's a signal that
emerges during conflict in the pre SMA
will record from the cortex in these
patients as well and this is helping us
understand the circuits that mitigate
conflict when making motor decisions
again these are fundamental questions
and things that we want to learn about
the brain and things that we can only
learn from patients who are undergoing
their surgical procedures because we
don't have that ability in other
volunteers now how did the ethical
issues come to light you know I've been
doing this type of research for a little
while in another center who is involved
study has been doing it we went to
submit these to our IRB and we had no
problems at all the third site was new
to doing this type of work and the IRB
raised concerns that there could be
therapeutic misconception and my
immediate retort was but you know when
we do this patients say they want to
give back and for me that was great
justification I said you know if they
want to give back why should we get in
their way the question comes to light
which is you know is this actually true
and sufficient to justify their
involvement is altruism and their desire
to give back a sufficient notification
so put another way you know we often
focus on therapeutic misconception but
assuming therapeutic misconception is
completely accounted for and then that
means we are completely relying on
altruistic content meaning patients have
no therapeutic expectation but then they
must want to be altruistic and this
issue of whether altruism is sufficient
and whether it can be complicated by any
other factors is even more important in
those studies where there is no direct
benefit either to the patient or to
their group and so it becomes
exponentially more important to explore
so I'm going to hand this over to Ashley
to discuss that a bit further okay so
given the clinical context that Nader
has set up for us we are faced with a
fairly robust question right so does
altruism actually affect the ethics of
non-therapeutic invasive human
neuroscience research and I think you
know also as Nader alluded to there is
an assumption either implicit in the
ways that our ethical principles are
stated or in our everyday practice that
altruism is a kind of golden motive and
I think that this assumption is probably
the conjunction of two different
assumptions right so the first
assumption is that the presence of
altruistic motives say on the part of
these participants is always an ethical
positive so whenever we see it it's kind
of a good thing and the second
assumption I think we have is that
reports of altruistic motives are always
uncomplicated that we can fairly easily
and reliably tell when it is that
patients actually have
mystic motives so when the rest of the
talk what I'll do is I'll try to unpack
these of assumptions and I'll give some
arguments for how it could be that
altruism does affect the ethics of these
trials both positively and perhaps
negatively or give us pause for concern
and I'll say some things at the end
about on some epistemic worries about
how you tell when people are truly
altruistic and some practical concerns
about you know what we ought to do
moving forward to make progress on these
issues so the first and most
straightforward way in which altruism
may affect the ethics of these non
therapeutic trials is in promoting
informed consent
so our doctrine of informed consent
requires that participants consent be
informed right so not based on a
misunderstanding or a lack of
understanding of the risks benefits or
alternatives in the trial and it must
also be voluntary or free from coercion
or other undue influences so in the case
of therapeutic research if we look at
the chart on the left of the slide from
we we can ask a question right so we can
say why would patients agree to incur
additional risk by enrolling in the
trial and there's a fairly obvious or
reasonable answer that
that makes informed consent possible
right so it could be very reasonable for
someone to take on additional risk to
their health for the possibility of
therapeutic benefit even if that
possibility is small right and in many
cases enrolling in these types of trials
is in fact in the best clinical interest
of those participants but if we focus on
the non therapeutic case or the chart on
the right we don't have available that
same kind of answer because of course
there currently is no direct therapeutic
benefit for those participants so we
might feel like we're in a bit of a
puzzle right so we need to get informed
free consent so we're looking for a
reason for enrolling in these trials
that could be informed and free but we
can't use the same reason we use for the
therapeutic cases so we might start to
wonder whether there is a reason that
could be reasonably informed and free
and it has been suggested that the
presence of altruistic motives could
provide such a reason
so we know that patients may participate
or agree to enroll in trials for all
kinds of reasons right so it might be
that participants actually are agreeing
to enroll in non therapeutic trials
because they mistakenly believe that the
trial is therapeutic that could be a
reason or they could enroll because they
have feelings of debt to their surgeon
they feel like they can't say no but
notice that those reasons are ethically
concerning right it would raise some red
flags about the possibility of informed
and free consent but altruism on the
other hand and the presence of an
altruistic motive at least at first
glance doesn't have those same kinds of
problems right so the participant says
look I know I won't benefit and I know
my condition will not improve but I want
to help Society and I care very much
about helping scientists understand the
brain that kind of reason right actually
looks like it's based on a proper
understanding with the goals of the
trial and doesn't yet on its own give us
cause for concern about coercion and
undue influence so the next way in which
altruism may affect the ethics of these
types of trials is in talking about the
risk benefit assessments of these trials
so one of our other pillars of research
ethics is that the risks be reasonable
in relation to the benefits right so the
federal common rule requires IRB s to
determine that risks are reasonable in
relation to anticipated benefits if any
two subjects and the importance of the
knowledge that may reasonably be
expected to result so IRB IRB committees
on ask or an explicit delineation right
of the rest of the trial benefit to the
individual benefits to society and a
risk benefit analysis but in the case of
non therapeutic invasive neurologic
research the mouthful right applying
this rule is particularly difficult
right for a few reasons
so the first is that the relative rarity
of the investigative techniques that are
used in these types of trials can result
in a kind of uncertainty about what the
actual risks are and that fact
compounded with the fat
that harm to the brain right or
neurological arm may be more
consequential than harm to other organs
can give us pause for concern right so
we have some challenges here and really
being able to delineate the rest of a
trial in a meaningful way on the benefit
side of things you know we might ask you
know how how are we supposed to
appropriately value say a piece of
scientific knowledge how much weight do
we give that benefit right or an
expected increase in knowledge about
some particular part of the brain right
how do we value that and there's also
questions about what ought to count as a
benefit right so currently as the
federal common rule states we're only
really considering direct therapeutic
benefits to the participant or else
benefits to society but it is kind of an
open question whether there are other
types of benefits we ought to consider
and I'll return to that shortly
the last challenge which I'll just
mention briefly is that we have to then
work out what a reasonable ratio would
be and in the case of non therapeutic
studies we're trying to balance personal
risk with benefit to society and it's
not at all clear what would actually
count as a reasonable ratio what how
much risk personal risk is actually
reasonable in relation to how much
knowledge about the brain so I'll add
that currently you know when there is no
direct benefit to the individual right
the only other benefit that we consider
in conducting this assessment is benefit
to society and given that there's quite
a lot of non therapeutic research
happening that implicitly suggests that
in many cases the benefits to society
are sufficient to outweigh the risk but
it's worth pausing to ask yourself you
know whether that's justified or on what
grounds is that actually true so to kind
of tie that into our case about altruism
it has also been argued that altruism
may count as a kind of benefit to the
participants in the trial so it may be
that being able to pursue your goals
goals that you care about or your
altruistic goals may contribute to an
increase in your well-being
overall well-being right and it may very
well be that an increase in your
well-being ought to count as a kind of
benefit in these types of assessments so
just as you know being able to donate
money to a cause that you care deeply
about might possibly increase your
quality of life or your sense of
well-being being able to participate in
the trial whose goal you care deeply
about may also contribute to your
well-being so you know it's it's an open
question I won't argue whether in fact
we should count altruism as a benefit
but it's an open question and we're
already using these concepts in our
ethical assessments and it's worth
pausing to consider whether altruism
ought to count it's also worth noting
that in clinical medicine right we care
you know we care about more than simply
survival right we also care about
quality of life and it's plausible that
an increase in well-being is intimately
connected to an increase in your quality
of life it's worth pausing also to
reflect on you know what we have to face
if we don't count altruism as a kind of
benefit on that risk risk benefit scale
right without altruism or without any
direct benefit in our best case
scenarios the risk benefit assessment in
non therapeutic research is I would say
ethically concerning right how is it
permissible to allow someone to take all
of the risk for zero benefit is really
the situation we're facing and the
standard answer to this is to appeal
back to consent
look we allow people to consent to
minimal risk with no benefit because we
value autonomy right there's one of the
explanation that's given but notice that
this explanation doesn't say that the
risk benefit ratio in these cases is
reasonable in fact it just explains the
ratio or or justifies the ratio by
appealing back to consent so notice that
if altruism weren't account as a kind of
benefit it would be a way to kind of add
to the benefit and change that risk
benefit ratio directly so that might be
a kind of ethical positive for us so so
far it might start to seem like I'm
building a case for altruism in fact
being
a golden motive right maybe it helps
with informed consent maybe it helps
promote beneficence towards the
participants themselves but I would just
you know for the last part of the talk
pause to remind ourselves that the
presence of altruistic motives while
maybe it's promising in these other
areas does not absolve us of all of our
robust ethical concerns and one concern
that I'll talk about briefly is
exploitation right so this is another
color of research ethics to protect
research participants from exploitation
and we can see its surface here in this
quote from a manual when learning
grading I'll just read the first part of
it the overarching objective of clinical
research is to develop generalizable
understanding of human biology subjects
who participate are the means to
securing stuck knowledge by placing some
people at risk of harm for the good of
others
clinical research has the potential for
exploitation of human subjects so
exploitation is commonly taken to be
taking unfair advantage of a person's
vulnerability for the sake of advancing
one's own end and the point here is
pretty simple right so the presence of
altruistic motives just does not on its
own preclude the possibility of being
exploited so we still have a lot of work
to do regardless of how the first part
of this talk turns out and the point is
simply that norms about exploitation do
not reduce to norms about informed
consent or norms about arrests a
favorable risk benefit ratio especially
in the non therapeutic case that's just
the kind of a complicated way of saying
that you can be exploited or treated
unfairly in enrolling in the trial even
when you consent to that treatment right
and you can be exploited or treated
unfairly in enrolling in a trial even if
the risks to you are reasonable in
relation to the benefits to society um I
would add that if altruism does count as
a benefit we should take into account
for these trials then maybe that is
helping a little bit with exploitation
because then in these cases the
participant is getting something a
direct benefit in some way but it still
doesn't absolve us of all of our worries
for the following reason
and the first of this so it's plausible
that there are ethical limits to
altruistic sacrifice right and that not
all such sacrifice is reasonable and so
then if this is so taking advantage of
someone's willingness to make those
sacrifices maybe wrong it's also
possible that altruistic behavior may
stem from feelings of self-loathing and
self-worth and so taking advantage of
someone's willingness to make those
sacrifices may also be wrong now this
can kind of compound with the fact that
participant populations in these cases
are already highly vulnerable suffering
suffering from debilitating neurological
disorder disorder and many are also
socially isolated so now that we've
walked through some of the ethical
issues I'd like to end with some
practical concerns the first are some
epistemic worries right that we don't
have well-developed tools for assessing
altruistic motivation so even when
patients report altruistic motivations
we don't currently know how to assess
those in light of some of the other
worries about vulnerability and
exploitation and we also know that there
are many factors that may influence
patients reporting altruistic motives
such as the belief that they will be
more likely to be accepted into the
trial if they report being altruistic or
the belief that they ought to be
altruistic so we have some worries here
about being able to really tell when it
is that patients are altruistic and
given the ethics it really seems to
matter that we get it right so now I'll
turn it over to Nader to talk about some
practical issues so as we design studies
in the future we have to both be aware
of these concerns about altruism but
also learn more about it so future
studies should really impact our
understanding of how participation
changes the subject sense of well-being
as well as their sense of valued Society
we need to really reflect as well on our
consent process and how it enables or
might complicate our understanding of
patients altruistic motives thank you
very much for this opportunity thank you
to pretend and dr. fine singer for that
compelling presentation please remember
to submit your questions for dr. Ponton
and dr. fine singer will answer them in
the live battle Q&A taking place today
at 11:20 a.m. Pacific time 2:20 p.m.
Eastern Time
please join us for this unique
opportunity to interact directly with
our renowned experts to discuss in our
ethics and the ethical considerations of
using new newer technologies we hope to
see you there coming up next dr. Francis
Shen will continue the neuroethics track
and present from lab to law neuroscience
in the heart worm